concept
bending a plane in the same direction as
the hand is moving
bending through wheel plane and floor
plane
while the hand moves in the wall
here the hand is leading the poi
the boy can leave the hand
the hand can lead the poi
it's good to find a comfy combination in
between
introverting the power method and iso
bend in the east coast method we can put
any number of petals four petal box
four petal diamond we can do six petals
do eight petals
concept anti-bending the plane we bend
the plane in the opposite direction the
hand is moving
from floor plane to wheel plane to floor
plane around the outside of the donut
extraverted impala method
anti-bend in east coast
okay four petal diamond isobend slash
introverted
we're out on the vertical axis in at 45
out on the horizontal axis in at 45 out
on the horizontal axis either rotating
away from the heart
when the poi is in or toward the heart
when the boy is in here we have toward
the heart
here i'm doing my best to mix btg 2
4-pedal diamond anti-spin with 4-petal
diamond iso bend slash introverted
we're moving away from the heart hand is
moving in under
boy moving toward the heart the hand is
moving in overhand
here we have box introverted 4 or box
iso band 4.
moving from in
to out on the 45 in to out on the 45 in
create this nice
diagonal
box iso band interpreted
mixing with vtg2 box anti-spin
bending from wall plane deploy to the
wheel floor combination of the toroid to
wall plane once again
sweet
uh
oh shizzle here comes anti-bend
or extroverted moves around the outside
the donut
this is a four-petal anti-bend
extroverted
give ourselves grace beats or move
smoothly from one
axis to the next changing from
away to toward away from the heart
toward the heart
take out those extra pedals
and make a two pedal anti-band
or two petal extra river
here we are out on the vertical
in on the horizontal
out on the vertical
in on the horizontal moving away
vtg2
two pedal horizontal in spin equivalent
is
to pedal anti-bend or two pedal
extroverted
yes
okay here's another one out on the
horizontal
in on the vertical moving away out on
the horizontal
in on the vertical moving away here it
is
two pedal anti-band vertical
compile vertical extroverted
here i'm doing my best to bend between
two pedal vertical anti-bend extroverted
and two pedal vertical in spin vtg2
shape equipment
now the boy moving away from the heart
when the poi is pointing in
so
all right here's a toroid pendulum
starting with this little pendulum and
then moving it into a figure eight it
sort of bends into real planes we're
like together same wheel plane kind of
cool pendulum together same wheel plane
we're gonna bend that all the way up
into floor plane
do a little slice
and do it on both sides
passing through that
figure eight in the middle
and then pulling it up into floor plane
on the side
here we have forward and wheel plane boy
moving together saying
slicing up into floor plane together
saying
moving away from
floor plan on the opposite side
swinging down
to figure eight across the top as well
same as below
you